[MUSIC PLAYING]
SIMON MORRISON: "Within
the Quota" dates
from the early 1920s.
It was premiered
in 1923 and toured
throughout Western Europe
and the United States
by a company called
the Ballet Suédois.
It's a work that disappeared
from ballet history
despite being really prominent,
popular, good reviews.
It has music by a fabulous
composer named Cole Porter, who
is an American classic
America’s songwriter,
and the fact that he actually
composed a piece for stage
for dance is little known.
This current project
is about kind
of restoring Cole Porter to
Cole Porter in terms of style,
and this kind of --
JULIA JANSEN: Princeton
University Ballet
is performing
"Within the Quota."
It is a production in which an
immigrant comes to the United
States and encounters all
of the American stereotypes
that he has of American society.
The way we've updated
"Within the Quota"
is that we've added a political
element to every character
in the original production,
and this element
consists of an alteration
of the character
to reflect a policy issue
or political issue which
we're facing today, and more
specifically immigration.
Yeah, that works.
SIMON MORRISON:
The music is being
played by Penguin Cafe, which
is a professional ensemble based
in London.
And they were very enthusiastic
about taking on this piece A,
because they're interested
in doing more work with dance
and B, because they're all
over the 1920s and Cole Porter.
And because one of
the local schools,
the Stuart School for Girls,
has a wonderful design program,
we were able to work
with them on developing
the various slides that are
shown during the performance.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAIGE SHAW: This is a really
interesting project for me
as a history major and
historian because we
get to look at this
ballet, which was basically
lost to history, and take
that original plotline,
original Ballet
Suédois production,
and bring it into
the contemporary era.
So it's been really interesting.
Julia and I thought a
lot about the characters
and what their contemporary
roles are, what
their roles are now in today.
SIMON MORRISON: This work,
when it was premiered,
was political because it was a
complaint against immigration
restrictions.
Obviously, no matter how
you perform it nowadays,
that parallel is easy to make.
During periods of crisis,
the arts really matter,
and if you are
actually going to make
a point, political or
otherwise, the arts
is the best vehicle for it.
And as I said to the students
involved in this production,
if you can, go for
it in this context.
You know, making a statement.
We're actually
offering a solution.
When can you, and in what
context can you do that?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SWANEE GOLDEN: For me, dance
has always been kind of a way of --
a mode of self-expression, a
way to kind of express myself
and my feelings on things but
through a physical activity.
So to have the
opportunity to react
to the current political
times in a method of dance
will be kind of supported,
not only by the University
but by an orchestra, an
international orchestra,
is an incredibly
amazing opportunity.
And I think it's really
amazing what Julia and Simon
Morrison have done,
in terms of updating
the characters and the
roles so that they're
so relevant to today's time.
I think that'll really engage
the audience in a way that's
pretty different
than anything else
we've done here at Princeton.
JULIA JANSEN: It
is a ballet which
invites everyone,
invites all Americans,
invites international students.
It's not made for a single
group of individuals.
It's made for everyone.
And I think is the
bottom line of the story
is that America, as a
society, despite the hardships
that we're going through,
is a place for everyone.
It's a place of
hope and prosperity.
We are not exclusive.
PAIGE SHAW: We're presenting
these opposing characters
and one represents
progression and liberalism
while the other kind of
represents conservatism,
and neither is
conquering the other.
They're kind of just
interacting in the end.
So there's no real resolution,
but in the end of the ballet,
you do feel this
sort of hopefulness
and this positive
optimism for the future.
[MUSIC PLAYING]